agent Hobbs
[Music]
sir unfortunately we've been informed
they likelihood
of agent Chandler making a full recovery
is slim
all signs point
the loss of brain function
okay
we don't have to issue
executive order
confiscate his intelligence sir this is
now confirmed it's not a hundred percent
we're still dealing with a living human
being
and we're dealing with millions of human
lives right millions that are protected
by the talents the likes of agent
Chandler's so let me play something PETA
is talent it's no longer any use to us
is it always what's useful or what's
right and wrong let's buy some tell ya
betta the world is made up of two things
black and white and there's nothing in
between with all due respect now you
have your order do as you're told
[Music]
don't start don't worry what happened
when I went to Vietnam
he came home okay and what happened when
it went you duffer
I always come home dozen high-ranking
terrorist planning war hell of a party
exactly when and where we do not know
but what we do know is that there is
information out there and I'm gonna
saying you go get it
yes sir this is a one-way ticket these
are my orders Peter this is a suicide
mission
[Music]
Kelly isn't a common is the intelligence
fully retrievable we would destroy our
agent process that was the risk he was
prepared to fight when he upset that is
decided they're gonna have to kill me if
they want to kill him what was his
mission it's classified contestants
looking for answers
the wife has attempted to get
intelligence
[Music]
don't get in our way you have
intelligence that will save the live
[Music]
you have to accept the reality of the
situation here
welcome to nah no terror
you